That feels weird but i'll allow it when mysterio
revealed my identity my entire life got screwed up
I was wondering if maybe you
could make it so that he never did
Welcome back everyone this is my new spider-man
no way home video for spider-man's new black
suit based on some of the leaked trailer
footage we know how he gets the suit and
what's going on with it we also got a brand
new scene of doctor octopus getting an iron man
upgrade to his octopus arms like iron man
technology combined with his octopus arms so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the eternals movie is out this weekend so we're
doing a giveaway for movie tickets all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
all your predictions for spider-man no way home on
the video i'll talk about spider-man's black suit
first then i'll talk about doctor octopus using
iron man technology but spider-man is wearing this
new black suit in a couple of the trailer scenes
first when he's running through what looks like
one of the feast shelters with his mask off and
everyone pointing him through like helping him
find a path or find a villain that he's trying to
chase or just escape from the police before they
can catch him the second scene is later when he's
fighting electro and sandman there could be other
sinister six villains during this fight scene but
the only ones visible in the trailer are electro
and sandman like you see the yellow lightning
combined with the dust that's slowly rising up
forming into a face here and spider-man sort of
cowering down here in the bottom right corner of
the frame trying to shield himself from everything
the black suit itself is just being called the
black and gold suit on all the merchandise so
that's probably its official name even if nobody
actually calls it that during the movie the
fingertips are still the same red and black as
the newer advanced dude from spider-man far from
home that's the red and black steve ditko inspired
suit they're just calling that the advanced suit
you've also probably seen some promos of the black
suit where spider-man is wearing special magical
looking doctor strange gauntlets like the way they
wrap around his arms here seem exactly the same as
the design of the bandages that are wrapped around
doctor strange's costume the gauntlets that he
wears they're cloth looking gauntlets but they're
still kind of like gauntlets even though the one
spider-man is wearing are gold as if somehow
those are part of the enchantment that doctor
strange lays on spider-man that allows him to
temporarily use magic like you see the suit laced
with all this blue energy magic like he's using
it as a shield he's using it to lace his webbing
so we have to make the obvious comparisons to the
anti-shock costume and the anti-ock costume from
spider-man ps4 and the miles morales uptown pride
costume it looks exactly like that and the whole
notion of spider-man wearing black suits still
waiting for that spider-man symbiote saga that
they teased with the spider-man vs venom movie
in the venom let the be carnage post-credit scene
but here's the funny thing about the black suit
like everybody has all these crazy theories about
how he gets it how he uses it what the technology
is how it works they're doing all these cool
things with it giving spider-man magic basically
for at least a little while but here's the thing
the black suit isn't actually a totally new suit
at least based on this leaked trailer footage
it seems like it's technically still the advanced
suit the red and black one if you saw that leaked
trailer footage recently before sony took it
down the footage depicts this random person just
running up to spider-man on the street after he
stopped a criminal like he's a mysterio supporter
and just tosses a bunch of paint or something
some giant fluid on spider-man's advanced suit
so it seems like spider-man literally just
takes the suit off and turns it inside out
and it's black and gold on the inner layer like
this is what the advanced suit looks like on the
inside and i think that's why even though most
of the suit has this really cool black and gold
design like the gold running all through it the
fingertips are still the exact same red because
red kind of clashes with black and gold in a bad
way like why would he have a black and gold suit
but weird looking red fingertips i think they're
the same red color as the advanced suit because
they're literally the same red hand pieces from
the advanced suit just flipped inside out so when
he's using magic here in whichever fight this
winds up being the doctor strange gauntlets seem
like the only actual brand new piece of costume
brand new piece of the suit that he's wearing
practically the only reason why spider-man would
be using doctor strange magic as cool as it is
would be as an upgrade to help him match whatever
the villain's abilities are like you have all
these sinister six villains that are getting their
own upgrades during the movie who are just way too
much for him to handle on his own usually that's
the reason spider-man gets his new suits or builds
his new suits to help guard against whatever
weakness his previous suits had against their
abilities as for the whole doctor octopus iron man
upgrades to his octopus arms if you notice in all
the doctor octopus scenes they released last week
i did a bunch of videos for them so i'll link them
below in the video description they're all taken
from that big bridge fight scene that they keep
hyping on the george washington bridge where he's
in the iron spider costume just getting thrashed
by doctor octopus and it looks like he basically
destroys the iron spider suit with his arms so rip
iron spider suit pressed f in the chat to
pay respects but a couple days after all
those empire scenes and previews dropped they
released a totally different preview of him
also from that fight but with red and gold iron
man looking octopus arms so at some point in the
fight the arms go from the old color like the
exact same arms from spider-man 2 to the iron
man version the big theory is that because the
arms are sentient they have the will of their
own you see doctor octopus kind of fighting them
for control of his own mind at times something
in my head he's right
listen
listen to me now it was a big plot point during
spider-man 2. during their fight on the bridge
when he's got spider-man dead to rights at some
point he's able to use his octopus arms to destroy
the iron spider suit and take the nanites that
form the suit integrating them with his old arms
like during the middle of the fight he takes
spider-man's iron spider nanites and uses them
to upgrade his octopus arms and it's a huge deep
cut easter egg for the very first iron man movie
back in 2008. i mentioned this a little while ago
too in one of my other videos but some of you may
remember this reference if you've been following
the making of the marvel movies since back in
phase one originally back in 2007 2006 when they
were first figuring out iron man's origin story in
the mcu for that first movie kevin feige and the
marvel people initially wanted to connect iron
man's backstory to spider-man on a fundamental
level early on spider-man characters and they were
going to do it by saying that iron man was the one
who designed doctor octopus's arms in the tobey
maguire spider-man movies because you have to
remember when they were developing the first iron
man movie it was around the time spider-man 3 had
just come out so we were still in tobey maguire
spider-man era it was before sony rebooted into
the andrew garfield amazing spider-man franchise
but this is kevin feige trying to connect the
tobey maguire spider-man movies to the mcu
at the very beginning and if you didn't realize
early on kevin feige was a producer on those tobey
maguire spider-man movies so he was working
with sony while they were making those from
the very beginning but because sony was trying
to reboot the franchise with andrew garfield
they said no way not gonna happen we're not gonna
let you use all these doctor octopus plot points
so marvel just had to delete that idea from the
first iron man movie but i guess what would have
happened is that we would have had an auto
octavius easter egg at some point during the
film like doctor octopus wouldn't have starred
in iron man 1 they would have just mentioned him
so by having doctor octopus use iron man tech
and spider-man no way home now in present day
it's kind of a way for them to bring a version of
that concept back like linking doctor octopus's
technology to iron man and because all the tom
holland spider-man movies are heavily influenced
by the iron man character you kind of expect
a few iron man easter eggs in here somewhere
it's also a really easy way to make doctor octopus
seem like he's way more badass and way more of a
threat to spider-man like i'm going to take that
really cool suit of yours and make it my cool suit
speaking of tobey maguire crossover i also just
did a big video for that willem dafoe green goblin
first look in spider-man no way home for what
he's actually going to look like when he shows up
i'll add a link for that down in the description
below during that video i also explained how it's
even possible for him to still be alive because
we have the pumpkin bombs we have his lap but
people are like wait a minute didn't he die
on tobey maguire's earth before doctor octopus
showed up so if doctor octopus is here how did
willem defoe's green goblin come back to life
it's all about the way doctor strange's spell
works and pulls things from across the multiverse
from space and time not just from alternate
places in the multiverse but from alternate time
periods in the multiverse and if we're talking
about black suits as for tom holland actually
wearing the symbiote the way that andy circus was
talking about the spider-man versus venom movie
it sounds like he doesn't think that it's
going to happen until after at least one more
different venom solo movie so i would say at
least like three years before we see spider-man
versus venom but that would be the movie where
we actually see him get the symbiote for the
first time and then after that movie we'll
probably see the symbiote start using the
classic spider-man symbol on his chest speaking
of multiverse we also just got the morbius trailer
with easter eggs that are seemingly used
in a way that don't totally make sense from
all the different spider-man franchises and the
venom movies half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since that
thing in san francisco wants to control you
hey uh doctor mike moon i should stay in
touch the hell are you matt i am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael morvius
we have the mcu michael keaton vulture from
spider-man homecoming the tom holland mcu
spider-man mysterio murder plot points but
it's the tobey maguire spider-man costume
and it's the tobey maguire daily bugle mentioning
rhino and black cat villains but we also have the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man version of
oscorp despite the fact we know it's the willem
dafoe version of green goblin from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies inside spider-man
no way home you just have to picture the sony
executives having the craziest meeting you've ever
seen trying to figure this stuff all out how many
easter eggs do we want for spider-man movies yes
but what's going to be happening this weekend
because the eternals movie is out in theaters
my eternals post credit scene video will post
tomorrow so be sure to see the movie when you have
the chance there's a bunch of stuff to talk about
my full movie breakdown easter eggs and a bunch of
bonus videos will also post later in the weekend
so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss anything we'll get a new
spider-man no way home trailer in another couple
weeks as well too everyone click here for my
eternals video about how thanos saved the avengers
in earth from the celestials and click here for
my full morbius trailer breakdown in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!